like for instance uh
let's go back to
hellboy hellboy to the golden army we're
filming right there's a whole sequence
that he was going to do a tracking shot
around me uh that was
um just he wasn't going to cut away to
anything so he hadn't it was going to it
was just a one-shot scene quickly with
me doing things with props putting a
contact lens in spritzing my my gills
with things and i was a fish man in that
movie right uh so
uh so as as the camera was tr it was on
a circular track going around me
and he wasn't going to get any coverage
on this to cut away to something else so
he had to get all of this action done in
a certain amount of time
so i was
so take one i'm going through all of the
beats that we had rehearsed
and
he is at the end of take one he says cut
doggy you're boring me to tears that's
all i had to say and i knew exactly how
to fix it really yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah because we once you know each other
they're boring me too you're right right
in the shape of water uh another fish
man character i played for him um
uh he might stop me at some point go cut
dougie
a noise and i was like got it i know i
knew what to do the next time what does
that mean well because we had talked
about uh the difference between those
two these two fish men that i've played
for him
one is very intelligent and refined
gentlemanly uh uh and the other one is
an animal from the wild right big
difference right so uh so he would
remind me you're an animal i don't want
to see any guy any human i want to see
the animal side of you so so if he saw
a human reaction or gesture from me as
the amphibian man in the shape of water
he would just go doggy
just to remind me animal
right so yeah you develop a shorthand
was there ever a moment where he just
was so astonished by you and what you
had done and brought to it that you you
did something that
non-verbally right that he was like
doggy what like he was so happy
does he get that way does he get kind of
animated and happy yeah he totally does
oh when he like he's he's he is such a
a grown-up kid i love him i knew that i
met i noticed that about him the first
time i met him on mimik many years ago
back in 1997.
he's he's a he's a big kid and i think
that's why he's such a great director
and why audiences love him is because he
he makes things that'll make the kid in
him go
you get excited yeah that's what he
makes he makes things that will he'll
that will give himself a geek chasm
therefore we all get one when we watch
his work